we have another new update on the Harry
Potter TV show this one coming to us
again from deadline and it indicates
that a big decision could be coming very
soon there's also a brand new name
that's been thrown into the mix for us
to consider so just to catch you guys up
a couple of weeks ago deadline put out a
report that stated WB and Max Executives
had met with four writers to hear how
they would go about adapting the
original Seven book series from there
the executives would pick their finalist
to move forward to the next round which
would include a meeting with author JK
Rowling in the UK now according to
deadline the four names being considered
were British writer Martha Hillier
mostly known for her work on the last
Kingdom Kathleen Jordan creator of the
teenage bounty hunters Tom Moran the
British writer behind the devil's hour
and Michael Lesley writer for The Hunger
Games the ballot of song birds and
snakes well now we have a new name from
deadline that's apparently being
considered Francesca Gardner is
reportedly one of three finalists to
land the job and guys I got to say
Gardner has some really impressive
credits to her name she served as
producer on HBO's Amy award-winning
series succession as well as producer on
the HBO adaptation of his dark materials
she also wrote one episode for the man
in the High Castle and was a producer on
killing Eve all of those shows have
pretty solid review scores among both
fans and critics with succession
obviously being the standout I think
it's also a plus that she already has
experience adapting a fantasy book
series in his dark materials and just to
dig into that one a bit more she was the
executive producer specifically on six
episodes of the third season and if you
take a look at those review scores even
further season 3 was Far and Away the
top choice of critics now fan reception
appears to have been more mixed I did
make sure to read through some of those
though to try and get an idea of what
exactly the fans didn't like as much and
to me it seemed like most of the
criticisms were actually directed at the
source material rather than any mistake
or shortcoming of the adaptation but if
you're a fan of his dark materials and
you've seen the show I'd love to hear
from you so let me know in the comments
what you think now another quick note
here on Franchesca is it sounds like she
may already be a fan of the series just
take a listen to how she answered this
question in an appearance on the
elevator podcast I always had the really
unappealing um desire to be top of the
class and and you know I feel very
strongly aligned with the herione
archetype fantastic yes which is which
is you know it has its its benefits and
also has its huge downfall my cudos as a
as a social being at school was was not
very high but my um my love of learning
um was the thing that that
made School enjoyable for me and I don't
know about for you guys but for me my
number one criteria that I want to see
and the person that they choose to lead
the show is someone who is a true fan of
the series someone who really gets these
characters who understands the book
characters before they became movie
characters and obviously we can't say
for sure that Franchesca knows and
understands all of that just based on
that answer but I do think it's very
good to hear and I actually listen to
that whole podcast that she was on
there's way more in there about her
writing and her experience if you're too
rigid about it you will not do well so
you have to you have to be flexible but
also in order for it to be good and for
it to keep its Artistic integrity it's
huting for me to use those terms but
it's in order for it to keep its the
thing that makes it good the the the
spark of the idea in the first place you
also have to be protective of it as well
so if she ends up being the pick that
may be a fun one to actually go back to
and see what all we can pick up on in
terms of her writing technique now I did
mention three finalists for the new
Potter show but unfortunately we don't
know the names of the other writers who
moved on to the second round presumably
with Garder we also aren't sure if this
is the stage where rolling has become
more involved of course as we talked
about last time she would absolutely
need to sign off and be a major part of
that final decision for now it seems
that WB and Max are still declining to
comment but deadline had a note in their
article that seems like they feel a
decision could be very close to
Happening Now who knows how reliable
their sources are but it seems that
deadline feels very confidently and they
have been breaking a lot of stories
recently on this new Harry Potter show
so hopefully they're right and maybe the
next time I'm talking to you guys about
this we actually have a name and know
who is going to be leading this project
in the same article they also made sure
to again point out that Max is open to
the idea of doing more than one Potter
show which of course already has fans
speculating about possible spin-off
ideas I personally think there are so
many Fantastic ideas out there for other
things they can do in the Wizarding
World but I still do fully expect that
they are going to be focused and going
going all in on this Harry Potter reboot
at least to start this new phase of
Wizarding World storytelling Warner
Brothers Discovery president and CEO
David zaslav has been very vocal about
wanting the company to focus more on
their biggest IPS like Harry Potter in
fact it was their final big announcement
at the max relaunch event of all the
things they could have closed the show
with they chose to end it with the Harry
Potter announcement I think making it
incredibly clear that Harry Potter and
The Wizarding World as a whole are going
to be a huge Focus for this company for
the next decade because if you miss the
details on the show they are saying that
this is going to be a decade long series
and it's not just a show of course we've
talked about the games many times on
this channel but Universal has also
announced a brand new theme park and
they've confirmed it will have a new
Wizarding World section seriously these
details are incredible you can check out
that video on the left side of your
screen now for everything we know so far
about the Wizarding World of Harry
Potter Ministry of magic as always guys
thank you all so much for watching I'll
talk to you again soon